2020 may have been a little lackluster
when it came to live action comic book
movies and shows
but fear not next year looks more than
ready to make up for it
from the best of marvel dc and beyond he
has every live-action superhero movie
and series
coming in 2021 on january 15th
one division is set to kick off marvel
studios new era in television
and judging from the trailers it may
just be the weirdest marvel project yet
naturally elizabeth olsen and paul
bettany return as wanda maximoff
and vision after the devastating events
of avengers infinity war and end game
the two lovebirds are finally living a
peaceful happy existence and a perfect
suburban town
obviously there's just one problem
vision supposed to be dead
and the cracks soon begin to appear in
his new perfect life with wonder
the miniseries looks to be a loose
adaptation of both tom king's 2016
vision series
and the house of m storyline which could
open up a world of possibilities for
both the movies and tv shows
moving forward the arrowverse's own
superman has made a handful of cameos
and appearances over the years and
despite never being a main character
tyler heckland's portrayal of clark
superman became an instant fan favorite
so now the cw has finally decided to
give him his own spin-off series
superman and lois during this series
lois and clark return to smallville to
take care of some kent family business
deal with the trials and tribulations of
superpowered parenting
and face a new threat from a mysterious
villain in short
it's classic superman with a thrilling
twist
marvel fans have been clamoring for a
proper team-up between bucky barnes and
sam wilson
ever since captain america civil war
first hit theaters
it looks like marvel agreed too since
the falcon and the winter soldier
is due to hit disney plus on march 19th
this series will revolve around bucky
and sam teaming up together in the wake
of avengers end game
sam is struggling to feel worthy of
captain america's shield
while bucky is just hoping his
brainwashed head is back on straight
together the two tried to be everything
to the world that captain america was
but their lives are soon appended by the
emergence of an old enemy
civil wars villain helmet zemo and yes
don't worry there'll be plenty of
bickering along the way too
oh yeah i can see it working gear's
turning
oh they're malfunctioning they're on
fire
mobius has a second sony movie to be
based on a spider-man villain
after 2018 surprise hit venom jared leto
starts as michael morbius
a brilliant but frail biochemist with a
rare blood disorder
in a desperate attempt to cure himself
he accidentally infects himself with a
form of vampirism
turning him into morbius the living
vampire the trailer for morbius makes it
appear as though sony will be taking a
more sympathetic approach
to telling morbius his story just like
they did with venom
there's also something here for mcu fans
since morbius is set to feature michael
keaton's vulture
who was last seen in 2017's spider-man
homecoming
mobius is set for release on march 19th
ever since the release of the much
maligned justice league back in 2017
a small but vocal group of online fans
have been petitioning for the release of
zack snyder's cut of the movie
and in march 2021 it's finally happening
normally society would never have been
given tens of millions to recut a movie
that already underwhelmed fans and
critics but with the kobit 19 pandemic
killing the theater business
and warner brothers struggling to get
hbo max off the ground
desperation has led them to giving
snyder the green light
the new curt will reportedly be 4 hours
long with alternate story lines and
brand new footage being shot
including the appearance of the iconic
dc villain darkseid
of course it remains to be seen whether
or not warner brothers gamble will pay
off
but either way it'll be fascinating to
see how it all plays out
natasha romanov has long been the glue
that has held the avengers together
fans have been hoping for a black widow
movie for quite some time
and despite the character meeting her
maker during the events event game
they're finally getting one black widow
is set between the events of captain
america civil war
and avengers infinity war and finds
natasha travelling back to her homeland
of russia
to explore the mysteries of the red room
in which she was trained and brainwashed
along the way she reconnects with her
first found family who come together to
take down a mysterious foe from the past
the red rooms do head honcho taskmaster
originally due for release last may
black widow promises a high-stakes spy
thriller with a golden heart
although things may change the movie is
currently set for a theatrical release
on may 7th
2021 just when you thought you'd seen
the last of him
loki is back surprise
debuting on disney plus in may loki will
follow a pre-redemption
2012 version of the character who steals
the tesseract following the events of
the battle of new york
unfortunately for everyone's favorite
tricks to god he soon lands in the
custody of the time variants authority
a secret governing body charged with
policing the marvel universe's alternate
timelines
and realities obviously the tva aren't
exactly keen on the idea
of an alternate timeline version of the
god of mischief bouncing around with a
tesseract
so it looks as though they strike a deal
with him in a loose adaptation of the
agent of asgard
comic book series loki has the ability
to reset the mcu timeline in an enormous
way
or even forge a number of brand new ones
created by rick and morty writer michael
waldron
you can safely expect plenty of time
travelling nonsense
a bunch of alternate loki's and a whole
lot of chaotic fun
in 2018 venom became an unexpected hit
for sony
raking in a staggering 856 million
dollars
at the box office part of the reason the
movie succeeded was that it didn't take
itself at all seriously
instead leaning into that irresistible
comic book campus
of course tom hardy putting on a
genuinely manic performance didn't hurt
either
so naturally on june 25th hardy is
reprising the role of eddie brock in
venom let there be carnage
as dangerous as venom can be the sequel
promises to introduce another favorite
marvel character
that's even more deadly cletus cassidy a
serial killer who becomes a horrific
entity
known as carnage with woody harrelson
joining the cast as cassidy
venom let there be carnage is sure to be
if nothing else
a wild ride indeed the first phase 4
marvel movie led by a brand new
mcu hero chang chi and the legend of the
10 rings
promises to blend tons of martial arts
action with the zany mysticism of 2016's
doctor strange
starring seymou liu legend of the 10
rings finds
shang chi taking part in an epic
tournament where the winner will be
granted the legendary 10 rings
earning them immense amounts of power
early reports have indicated that the
fight sequences in the movie will be
incredibly dynamic
with everything from gritty hand-to-hand
fighting to more mystical
wushia sequences that may even feature
shang chi's comic book ability to create
clones of himself
liu has already won fans over with his
hilarious social media presence
so it will be great to see that natural
charisma translate to marvel's latest
hero throw in the legendary hong kong
actor tony liang as a mandarin
and maybe a cameo appearance or two and
you might just have the recipe
for 2021's biggest marvel movie we'll
find out for sure on july 9th
the 2016 version of suicide squad was
poorly received to say the least
despite introducing a number of fan
favorite characters
including margot robbie's harley quinn
luckily it seems the warner brothers are
up for giving the squad another chance
with james guns a suicide squad
which is set to release on august 6th
the sequel will bring back harley and a
number of og members
of the first movie squad however in true
james gunn fashion the movie will also
introduce well over a dozen new
superheroes
each weirder than the last gunners
promised that this is the craziest and
biggest movie he's ever done
and well who are we to argue eternals is
the second marvel movie of 2021
to usher in a host of new characters to
the mcu this time however it's a brand
new superhero team
the eternals are an ancient race of
superhumans who have been living in the
shadows for thousands of years
however following the events of avengers
ends game an unexpected event forces the
eternals back into the spotlight to take
on their most ancient enemies
the hideous deviants the cast of
eternals is absolutely stacked to say
the least
with richard madden playing icarus
angelina jolie astina
gemma china cersei salma hayek as ajak
kumayo nanjiani as kingo barry kuen as
druid
brian tyree henry as fastos lauren
ridloff as makari
liam akua sprite don lee as gilgamesh
and kit harrington as dane whitman also
known as the black knight
not much is known about the movie's plot
beyond the premise and the cast
but it'll be fascinating to see how
critically acclaimed director chloe zao
guides this new team of heroes into the
mcu eternals is due for release on
november 5th
after years developing the project
dwayne johnson's black adam is finally
hitting theaters on december 22nd
johnson has always been keen to bring
the story of black adam to life
as he'll be unlike most characters yet
seen in the dc eu
this is because adam isn't so much a
hero as he is an anti-hero at best
and the movie looks to be leaning into
the characters questionable morals
adam is a former slave who still carries
with him a zeal for justice
his powers are similar to shazam's but
adam's ruthless streak gives him a much
darker edge
for now the movie is still on track but
thanks to a number of pandemic delays
there's a chance that this one could be
bumped to 2022
after spending literally three decades
in development hell
a live action adaptation of neil
gaiman's beloved and critically
acclaimed graphic novel series
sandman will finally see the light of
day on netflix sometime in 2021
the sun man revolves around its main
character dream who is also the
eponymous sandman
dream is one of the seven endless
ancient beings who embody powerful
concepts
including death despair delirium
destruction
destiny and desire they've existed since
the dawn of time
and spend most of their time fulfilling
the functions of their name but as you
might guess
their sibling relationships are a little
dysfunctional much of the sandman deals
with dream learning that he can't
control everything and that all things
even him
must deal with the sins of his past
during its celebrated run the sandman
was the first graphic novel to win the
world fantasy award for short fiction
and has won more than two dozen eisner
awards the bram stoker award and the
hugo award
kamala khan first made her marvel comics
debut in 2013
and fans have been dying to see a
live-action adaptation ever since
newcomer iman valani has been cast as
kamala for the disney plus series
the character is a pakistani american
muslim teenager who lives in new jersey
and is obsessed with superheroes
including her favorite of all captain
marvel
when kamala is accidentally exposed to
the chemical terrorism mist however
it activates her dormant in human cells
turning her into a superhero
with shape-shifting powers since 2013
kamala has led the youth movement in
marvel comics
becoming one of the new wave of teenage
superheroes who are now coming to the
fore in marvel's disney plush shows
ms marvel is set to debut sometime in
late 2021 and it's already been
confirmed that kamala will be making an
appearance in future movies too
the last of 2021's disney plus series
hawkeye will find jeremy renau reprising
his role of clint barton
this time however the master archer will
be joined by a young apprentice cater
bishop
who in the comics takes over as the new
hawkeye when clint retires
what i get to do in the show ultimately
is shepherd an amazing
character to be ultimately probably a
better version of me
although there's bound to be plenty of
action hawkeye will likely be more of a
character study than fans might have
expected
in particular it seems that the series
will be borrowing heavily for matt
fraction's hawkeye my life as a weapon
which leaned heavily into its absurdist
dark humor as well as the struggles of
being a non-powered normal guy
trying to keep up in a world of
superheroes the mcu version of hawkeye
has always been at his best when
borrowing from the humor of fractions
run
so a whole series based off it is
nothing to be sniffed at
especially when it features one of the
most popular members of the young
avengers
but that's not all here are some of the
other superhero shows and movies due for
release in 2021
the king's man sylvester stallone
samaritan spider-man 3
batwoman season 2 black lightning season
4
the flash season 7 star girl season 2
the umbrella academy season 3 the boys
season 3
lucifer season 5 part 2 supergirl season
6
legends of tomorrow season 6 titans
season 3
and doom patrol season 3. check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one